welcome back time travelers we have all traveled
through time and space to be here and i am really
really excited today this is absolutely one
of my favorite lectures to give in class to my
my graduate students and i think this is going
to be one of the absolute most useful lectures
for you so today we're going to talk about one of
the most fundamental methods in solving partial
differential equations which is separation
of variables it's a way of turning a partial
differential equation like laplace's equation
into a system of ordinary differential equations
that we know how to solve and then we can
reconstruct this kind of spatial solution
of this this partial differential equation from
those those ode solutions so this is a cornerstone
of modern applied mathematics in engineering
in science in computation and so i'm going to
walk you through the separation of variables
and i'm going to introduce it specifically
to solve laplace's equation in two dimensions
for the steady state heat distribution on this
rectangular metal plate so we're going to
solve laplace's equation in 2d to find the
steady state heat distribution and we're going
to do it using separation of variables okay this
is a big one we're going to cover some of the
most important concepts in in engineering math
for example we're going to show that when we
take our separation of variables and we get
our system of ordinary differential equations we
will essentially derive that the fourier transform
sines and cosines the basis of sines and cosines
are the eigen functions of laplace's equation
on this domain so really important connections
and i'm super excited to walk you through this
believe it or not this is actually the first
weekend i'm back in seattle since our year-long
sabbatical at caltech and i couldn't wait i've
been planning a whole set of videos for a while so
i decided to come in and film this up all rightand
Whenever you solve a partial differential equation of course you need some combinationof initial conditions and boundary conditions
depending on if it's a PDE in space or in time...
for this Laplace's equation -- and remember Laplace's
equation del^2 u is just the second
partial derivative of u with respect to x
squared plus the second partial derivative of
u with respect to y squared equals 0. So this
is a partial differential equation because u is
a function of x and y and we are representing
conservation of thermal energy or the
steady state heat distribution in terms of these
partial derivatives with respect to x and with
respect to y. And we derived the heat equation
in the last lecture in two dimensions as
a conservation of thermal energy in a volume or
on a square on a rectangle, and if you take the
limit as time goes to infinity, that's what
I mean by steady state -- all the transients die
out -- then you arrive at this steady-state heat
distribution equation given by Laplace's equation.
Now we need some uh boundary conditions to makethis a well-posed problem
that we can solve and
so the first boundary condition on the left wall
so what we're going to assume is that we impose a
constant temperature distribution on the left wall
the top wall the right wall and the bottom wall
and so u at x equals zero that's the left wall
for all points y we're going to say that that
equals f 1 of y some some specified function f 1
which is a function of the y variable
which goes from 0 to some height
h similarly we're going to specify at the top
boundary condition u now this varies in x u of
x comma h equals f 2 and this is a function
of x because it varies in the x direction
we're going to specify a right boundary condition
u at x equals l for all of these points y equals
f 3. again this is a function that varies in y
and finally we specify our fourth boundary
condition at the bottom which is u of x again
fixed at y equals zero that's what the bottom line
equals f 4 and this is a function of x so
Okay, nowwe have a partial differential equation and enough
boundary conditions that this is a well posedproblem.
I'm going to walk you through solving
this using the separation of variables.
And thisis actually kind of a gnarly problem to solve with
all of these boundary conditions, and so one of
the things I really like to do in my class... I think
this is illustrative of how you take a complicated
problem like this and break it down into a simpler
problem... because Laplace's equation is linear
meaning if I had a solution u1 and a solution u2
and a solution u3, if I add all of those solutions
up that is still a solution of Laplace's equation...
it's a linear partial differential equation and so
what that means is that if I have this full set of
boundary conditions, where I have f1, f2, f3, f4
and I have my solution u(x,y)... that's my full solution...
this is equal to the sumof
four simplified problems where in the
first problem I have (f1,0,0,0)
okay, so I've kept my f1 boundary
condition but I made all of my other ones zero
we're going to call this u1(x,y) plus
another set (0,f2,0,0) plus (0,0,f3,0) plus
(0,0,0,f4). And again the solution of each of these
sets of boundary conditions is u1, u2, u3, and u4.
And because this is a partial differential equation
that is linear, if I add up these four solutions
u1, u2, u3, and u4 it is a solution again of Laplace'sequation
that satisfies the boundary conditions f1, f2, f3, and f4
at those four sides. So I'll show
you in this this video... so this is going to um...
my guess is this is going to be like 30 or 40 minutes
so buckle up... I'm going to pick this one here
because this is the easiest one for me to solve
with the boundary conditions and then as kind
of a homework problem you can solve these other
ones and add them up to get the full solution.
so i'm going to pick this problem here and i think
i should just probably write this out as uh this
is where we're gonna remember what problem we're
solving so we're solving del squared u equals zero
with the boundary conditions zero
zero f 3 0 let's call this f 3 of y
and i'm just going to write down my boundary
conditions to be very very explicit so i have u of
x comma 0. so u of x at the y equals 0 is 0.
i have u of x at the top of my square at h also
equals zero i have u of x equals zero all along y
equals zero and i have u of x equals l at the far
length of my domain for all points y equals this
f3 of y so these are my boundary conditions
this is the problem we're going to solve
and we're going to solve it using separation
of variables okay good i'm gonna erase this
because i need all the board space i have uh if
this takes too long to erase i might speed it up
all right uh time travel good so now we're
to solve this simplified problem of laplace's
equation using separation of variables and this is
an incredibly powerful technique which essentially
was introduced by uh jacob bernoulli in 1690. and
1690 was a very very interesting time in europe
uh mathematically so if you think about
it in that century from 1600 to 1700
kepler had used tico bray's data to solidify the
copernican model with the sun at the center of the
solar system galileo had been imprisoned or under
house arrest and died in his home in the middle
of that century and two or three years before
jacob bernoulli introduced the separation of
variables to solve this isochrone problem newton
released his principia so just an incredibly
rich time in in the history of math and physics
and i actually think that the separation of
variables is one of the culminations of
this kind of rich thought environment
so the idea is that we are going to take
our solution so we're going to say u of
x comma y this is a huge assumption we're
going to say that this equals some function of
x some function in the x direction times some
function in the y direction now this is a really
big assumption we're assuming that these dynamics
in x and y can be split into the product of
functions of x times functions of y now that
means that there are no weird cross terms here
like well this means that i can factor my
solution into a term a set of terms in x
and a set of terms in y but that it is separable
into into those two functions so i'd actually like
you to think of some examples of functions of x
and y that are inseparable that cannot be split
into this i'm thinking of things like x
plus y squared x plus y quantity squared um
is is not separable in this way i don't
think you should double check that i
just made that up on the spot okay so the
first assumption this is a huge assumption
is that we are going to assume this uh
separation of variables and then what
we're going to do is we're going to plug this
into our partial differential equation and we're
going to get ordinary differential equations
for f and for g that have to be satisfied so
let's do this so if i do del squared of u and
remember this is partial squared u partial
x squared plus partial squared u partial y
squared okay so um partial this and again we're
gonna do the chain rule so the second partial
derivative of this with respect to x is just f x x
subscript here means partial derivative
i took two partials with respect to x
times g of y now you could say plus f of x g x x
of y but since g is a function of y its partials
with respect to x are zero okay okay so this is
the first term of laplace's equation the second
derivative in x plus the second derivative in y is
again f of x g y y of y and of course this equals
zero okay we know that this equals zero good so
so this is laplace's equation if we assume that
we can split our function u into a product of f
x and g of y and so now what we're going to do is
kind of play around with these a little bit so i'm
going to move one of these over to the right hand
side because both of these add up to zero so i
can move one over to the right hand side and i
can say so i'm going to rearrange this and say f
x x of x times g of y equals minus f of x g y y y
and now i'm going to collect all of my f terms
on one side and all of my g terms on the other
everything that's a function of x and everything
that's a function of y on different sides of the
equation and i'm going to get f x x divided by
f these are both functions of x equals minus
g y y over g okay because these are um i
collected all my g my y terms over here and
all of my x terms over here good uh so this
if you think about it only is a function of
x so even though these are partial derivatives
with respect to x f is only a function of x so
these are just normal derivatives and these
are normal derivatives uh with respect to y
and one of the really cool things about
separation of variables is this next step
is that these two equations because they
equal each other these these two terms equal
each other they both have to equal constant
lambda so i'm going to say this is a constant
and if you have watched my videos before you
know that i love eigenvalues lambda so i am
calling this lambda because this is going to be
an eigenvalue you'll see that in a few minutes
but these two terms have to be constant and and
i always pause and i ask my students to think
hard about why this is so i'm going to
pause for a minute and you're going to think
i i got these equations by taking this you know
partial uh differential equation equals zero
so i moved terms over i divided and collected
like terms you know my x terms and my y terms
why do those have to equal a constant
and the answer is because if this is only a
function of x and if this is only a function
of y then for any y value i i vary you know this
equation it still has to be equal to this one at
every single x value so because this is only a
function of x and this is only a function of y
the only way that those can equal each
other is if it's the constant function
if it's like you know one equals 1 or 2 equals 2.
you can't have x equals minus y for all y and for
all x so the only way this is true for all y and
all x is that if they both equal a constant good
and so we're actually getting
really close to starting to solve
this problem so we've still set this up
and i'm going to take a big step back
or you can jump ahead to the summary or
you know i'm going to have these summary
moments where i summarize all of the steps
but i'm going to keep going just a little bit
so what we've done so far is we have assumed that
we can split our function into a product of f of x
times g of y we've plugged it into our partial
differential equation and now we have recovered
uh this relationship which i claim is two
systems of ordinary differential equations
so this in my mind is two systems of ordinary
differential equations we have uh f x x equals
lambda f okay this is a ordinary differential
equation in f of x okay f is a function of x
so you really could think of this as like f prime
prime equals lambda f we know how to solve this
and we have another differential
equation g y y equals minus lambda g
and if you're a little quicker than i am i've
been thinking about this so i know the answer
but if you're a little quicker than i was you'll
recognize that the solutions of this are going to
be things like plus or minus you know e to the
plus or minus root lambda t or root lambda x
and solutions of this are going to be things
like sines and cosines of root lambda y's
okay so these solutions of these are going to be
sines and cosines solutions of these are going to
be exponentials good and importantly these have
our boundary conditions here translate into like
initial conditions for our ordinary differential
equation so at f we're going to use our um
our x equals zero and x equals l conditions here
so f of zero equals zero and f of l uh f of l has
to equal f three of y okay this is a little
messy i'm going to i probably shouldn't have
written that down but the x equals l condition is
going to come from this one and similarly we have
these conditions on g g ones are easier which
is g at zero has to equal g at h has to equal
zero those are these uh these conditions here
okay so now what we have is we've turned our
nasty partial differential equation which is a
function of x and y you know two spatial variables
and we have by separation of variables shown that
now we can reduce this to two systems of ordinary
differential equations and these ordinary
differential equations it's actually a whole
family it's infinitely many ordinary differential
equations for any value lambda that i choose any
value lambda here this is absolutely true if
this is pi if this is negative 2 if this is 15
this is still true and so i get this whole
family of ordinary differential equations i solve
but i'll point out that even though any
constant lambda makes this true only special
lambda remember eigenvalues are special values
only special eigenvalues lambda will allow me
to satisfy these two sets of boundary conditions
uh these kind of ode initial conditions so that's
that's really important okay good um and i'm just
gonna think for a minute um yeah realistically
this uh i'm gonna i'm gonna erase this one we're
going to come back to this boundary condition so
so i think at this point you should you
should be seeing this looks like a much easier
system to solve because i have really easy my
boundary conditions give me really easy kind of uh
can constraints on on my solutions here
whereas the f variables are going to be nastier
because this right hand side imposed temperature
distribution so that's going to be a little hairy
so i'm going to solve this g-y-y equation first
i'm going to find which special lambdas allow
me to satisfy these boundary conditions and then
once we have those special lambdas we'll solve f
and we'll take all of our solutions and we'll
plug them back in to reconstruct u of x y okay so
that's what we're doing um good i think we should
just get into it um we're already pretty far into
it so okay so now what i want to do is i want
to solve my gyy equation um i might just do it
down here because i think i have enough space uh
okay so g-y-y now we have a few different cases we
could do it if lambda is positive or if lambda is
negative okay so if lambda let's say lambda is um
greater than zero okay i'll let you think about
what happens when lambda is equal to zero that's
an interesting case but but let's just think about
this for now so if lambda is greater than zero
then essentially this gyy equals minus lambda
g the solutions of this are sines and cosines
this is literally uh you know g prime prime
equals minus lambda g and we know so you
could uh you could assume you know if gy equals
e to the alpha y and you double differentiate it
you'll find that the eigenvalues of this have to
be complex conjugate pairs plus or minus i omegas
and so we know that we're going to
have solutions our sines and cosines
and so uh we're going to say
that our gys are equal to um
um
because g zero equals zero i can't have
any cosine components so i could write
down you know sine of root lambda y
plus cosine of you know root lambda
y but i can't have any cosine term because of
this boundary condition because the cosine of
zero is one it's not zero so i'm only going
to keep my sine term so sine of root lambda y
and now i have to find the really really special
root lambdas that satisfy both of these boundary
conditions so we know that sine of you know
root lambda y is zero when root lambda is 0
or pi or 2 pi 3 pi 4 pi 5 pi so i'm going
to basically say that if root lambda
equals some integer multiple of pi and
i'm pretty sure i needed this to be
okay so when g of h when i plug in so lambda root
lambda h has to equal an integer multiple of pi
when root lambda times h because i plug in h
here when that equals an integer multiple of pi
then this uh satisfies that right boundary
that top boundary condition so so that's my
condition is that root lambda equals n pi over
h essentially for all integers n for n equals
one two three four five six so on okay so uh
for n equals one two three dot dot dot dot
uh if n equals zero that's also fine you can kind
of work that out that if n equals zero then this
is just sine of zero it's just a it's zero uh
and so that's also totally fine so so now we have
come to a important kind of crux which is we know
that this equation was true for all lambda and so
these differential equations are also true for all
lambda but there are only very special lambda that
satisfied these boundary conditions the bottom and
top boundary condition of my pde and specifically
they're the they're the uh the lambdas that
satisfy this equation so that sine of root lambda
y equals zero when y is zero and when y is h now
it's easy every time y is zero this is zero but
when y equals h i need this special relationship
for lambda so lambda has to satisfy this equation
and i'm going to get rid of my uh my root here and
i'm going to square my other side so lambda equals
n pi over h quantity squared so if lambda
equals that for any value of n that's an integer
this is a valid lambda that
satisfies these boundary conditions
and so now what i have is a countably infinite
set of ordinary differential equations
for f and for g accountably infinite sets for
every n i get a lambda and i have a corresponding
ordinary differential equation that satisfies
my boundary conditions and the solution are
sines with that fundamental frequency of root
lambda in the in the vertical direction good
so i'm going to write this out just very very
explicitly so i don't forget i'm going to say
maybe probably should have color
coded this g of y equals sine
of n pi over h y so all of the functions g
in this separation of variables that satisfy
the top and bottom boundary conditions all of
them are of this form for an integer value of n
that's super cool so we've solved half the problem
check okay this video is going to go along we're
halfway through we've solved half of the problem
okay so now we have uh we know what these guys are
the g of ys are signs with uh these perfect kind
of harmonic so if you think about a guitar string
these kind of harmonic eigenvalues that satisfy
these boundary conditions actually very much like
a guitar where you pin this in two places there's
only certain signs and cosines that can exist and
satisfy those pin boundary conditions that's
another application of separation of variables
i'll show you in uh in another lecture
soon one of my favorites actually good um
i'll let you think about what happens
so we already talked about when lambda
equals zero that's the same as when n
equals zero that's a perfectly valid
boring solution where this is the zero
function so that's not interesting
and if lambda is less than zero that this is a
good homework problem if lambda is less than zero
then this equation now will have solutions e
to the plus and minus square root of lambda y
and there is no way of satisfying both
of these boundary conditions equaling
zero uh with e to the you know lambda y and you
know root lambda y plus e to the minus root lambda
y there's no way with just exponential functions
i can satisfy these two boundary conditions
so lambda has to be positive and it has to have uh
this very special set of lambdas to be to be valid
okay so essentially the big step one was that we
um i'm going to draw this out because i think this
is actually really important and i have a little
cartoon i draw in my class which is the the first
step after separation of variables and getting
this system of ordinary differential equations
was we solved the one with easy boundary
conditions always make your life easy solve
the easy boundary conditions first the ones that
are zero okay so in the y direction in this case
and what we did was we essentially said that
you know in the y direction from let's say
0 to h the only solutions that can satisfy
this differential equation with these boundary
conditions that it has to be zero at these
these conditions are these very very special
sine waves that have you know the right
i'm not very good at drawing sine waves but
very very special sine waves that have the right
frequency so that they exactly are pinned to zero
at the bottom and the top of my domain so that's
super cool okay and now the next step the second
step is that we're going to use these lambdas and
we're going to solve our hard ode in f okay so
now we're going to solve our od and f and we're
going to use the solutions of those eventually
we're going to use our boundary conditions to
uh to get the coefficients of this this function
okay good uh so that is what we're doing now so
we've just solved the the y's now we're going to
solve the f the f's and i think this actually
is not that bad so where do i want to do this
maybe i'll just cheat and use my notes
okay so we know that f x x equals
lambda which is n pi over h quantity
squared of f good and we know
that the solutions of this are going to be f
of x these are positive numbers here and so we
know that the solution of f prime prime equals a
positive number f is going to be some constant a
e to the n pi over h x plus some other constant
b e to the n pi the minus n pi over h x
and technically for every this is an ordinary
differential equation for every integer n it's a
whole separate differential equation so these are
possibly different coefficients a1 a2 a3 a4 for
each of those values of n so this is actually not
that bad i should have boxed this solution here
that corresponded to this solution here and
this is the solution of my x equation now
that i know that my eigenvalues have to be
root n pi uh or sorry have to be n pi over h
squared and here's where we get to use our
our easy x boundary condition so our easy x
boundary condition is that f of 0 has to be 0.
so i can plug 0 into both of these equations
and e to the 0 is 1. and so i get
f of 0 equals a n plus b n equals 0
which means b n has to equal minus a n okay so
anytime i see a b n i can just swap this out for a
minus a n i hope you caught what
i did i plugged in x equals zero
that killed the exponentials that just became ones
and i got a n plus b n has to equal zero which
means b n equals minus a n okay and i'm getting a
little out of space here but essentially the sum
of e to the plus you know alpha x minus e to the
minus alpha x is just a hyperbolic sine function
and so this uh f of x maybe i'll just
write it down here so my f of x is equal to
a n
it's actually equal to 2 a n hyperbolic sine
of n pi over h x good so all of my x solutions
have to have this form this is just a basic
basic like trig identity is that this equals 2
a n cinch of n pi over h x you can just you know
verify this yourself it's pretty easy if you like
complex analysis this is like a homework problem
and complex and so now we also have this term
good uh okay so i'm just going to barrel through
i'm going to go all the way to the end and write
out the whole solution and then we're going to
recap what we learned and we're also going to
think about like what happened if i had different
boundary conditions maybe i'll talk about that a
little bit if i had different boundary conditions
here these were fixed temperature i basically have
these uh sides let's say in an ice water bath so
that they're fixed to be temperature zero same
on the left side and maybe i hit the right hand
side with a blow torch to you know give it some
some constant thermal uh profile but you know so
these are fixed temperature u equals zero what if
the we had a no flux condition what if we
had an insulating boundary condition the
partial derivative of u sub x equals zero or
the partial derivative of u sub y equals zero
i'll i'll talk you through this in a little
bit but essentially what would happen is
we would get slightly different boundary
conditions here maybe we would get you know
g sub y of zero equals g sub y of h equals zero
in which case i would get cosine solutions being
the only ones that can satisfy that zero flux
condition and these would all become cosines um
other things uh other other things you could
do here i think if i had an insulating boundary
condition on the left then i would probably
get coshes here hyperbolic cosines i don't
quite remember you should work through
this yourself okay but so now what we
have is that the solution of this partial
differential equation uh in in u is equal to
and remember this will have this is true
for every single integer n for n equals 0 1
2 3 4 and so on and so because it's true for
all of those if i add up all of those solutions
that's the solution of u so for every single
lambda here i get one of these solutions and
if i add them all up that's my global solution
to you so this is equal to the sum from n equals
1 to infinity and the reason i'm not doing n
equals zero is because um it's boring because
sine of of uh zero is always zero so you could
do n equals zero and write this out but the first
term would be zero and we have i'm actually going
to write my f of x is first so i have my a sub n
times uh times what times let's say i could do
a of n cinch or a of n sine i'm just going to do
my sine first uh let me move my cinch first
i have n pi over h this is in the x direction
sine of n pi over h in the y direction so
it actually doesn't look that terrible i get
cinches in the x direction and i get signs in
the y direction okay and cinch is you know it's
going to look like a decaying exponential plus a
growing exponential so something kind of you know
almost catenary-ish and these are harmonic
to satisfy those boundary conditions in y
and i've gotten rid of this 2 here because i am
lazy and because this is a undetermined constant
so i can just say that i am defining
a to have that factor of 2 in there
this is the solution so this is the
actual solution of laplace's equation
okay actual solution of laplace's equation
using separation of variables now separation
of variables does not always work there are
problems that are non-separable okay there
are problems where you can't separate the solution
into a product of functions and x times a product
of functions in y uh plenty of examples of that
but when you so so what i would recommend is if
you think your problem is separable you make
this assumption you go through the steps and
if at some point you box yourself into a corner
where you can't satisfy your boundary conditions
or your initial data or whatever then you might
conclude the separation of variables doesn't work
but in this case we didn't hit any walls through
this procedure and we actually were able to derive
this full solution pde here okay so i did not
determine these coefficients a n yet this is kind
of a pain in the butt i will do this in a minute
these a and these undetermined coefficients a n
these are super important there is one boundary
condition i haven't used yet and that is this one
so if you think about all of the
steps we've done up until now
we've used the bottom and top uh boundary
conditions to solve my my functions in y to
get this this you know these perfect eigenvalues
and these eigenfunctions in the y direction
we have used the left boundary condition to for
our f equations to show that b has to equal minus
a which gave us cinches that give us the form
of this equation but these coefficients a n we
haven't determined what these are yet and the only
information left to determine these coefficients
are these uh this this kind of nasty boundary
condition on the right okay so i'm going to do
that in a minute um but what i want to do right
now is i just want to do a big recap okay because
some of you might not want to pay attention to
this you know deriving a and i think it's amazing
because this is going to basically use the fourier
transform if you think about it these coefficients
these coefficients are going to be the fourier
transform coefficients of this function f 3 in
this basis of sines so it's absolutely amazing
connection uh to fourier analysis um so the the
recap here for me is is the most important part
um we have introduced one of the most powerful
methods of solving partial differential equations
which is separation of variables 1690 bernoulli
and essentially it allows us to transform
our partial differential equation you make
this assumption you plug it into your partial
differential equation and you get out two systems
of ordinary differential equations you get a set
of ordinary differential equations in x and you
get a system of ordinary differential equations in
y where are my y's in y and we know how to solve
ordinary differential equations they're relatively
easy especially linear odes that are second order
all of our solutions are going to be exponentials
or sines and cosines that's it okay and so that's
you know that's that's a big step one is you know
step zero is assume you can split your variables
step one is plug it into your pde and derive a
system of odes out the next step step two is pick
the one that has easy boundary conditions not the
one that has hard boundary conditions the easy one
and find the special values of
lambda the special constants lambda
that uh allow you to satisfy those boundary
conditions and for me this is one of the most
beautiful parts is that those special lambdas
are actually eigenvalues they are honest to
goodness eigenvalues of this ordinary differential
equation that satisfy these boundary conditions
so we have eigenvalues lambda which are these
you know n pi over h squared for integer n
and the corresponding eigen function so these
are the eigen functions corresponding to those
eigenvalues lambda i'm actually going to write
down lambda n okay these are all uh these are
my lambda n's i have countably many eigenvalues
lambda that satisfy these boundary conditions
and corresponding i have eigenfunctions okay
so i used to have eigenvalues and eigenvectors
but now we have eigenfunctions because the
solutions are functions we live in a function
space a hilbert space if you want to learn more
about that check out my fourier analysis series
we talk all about you know fourier transforms
and these eigenvalues and eigenfunctions
okay that was step two i'm losing track here
i think that was step two solve the one with
the easy boundary conditions step three is now
that we have determined those special lambdas
plug those into our hard our differential
equation with hard boundary conditions
uh and one of the boundary conditions was easy
this one here so i use that to figure out that
bn has to equal minus a n that tells me that i
get cinches out and i am almost done that's like
three steps with a zeroth step and we get this
solution here and the only thing we haven't done
uh is solve for this a n and i'll just remind you
you know this is a homework problem i hope you all
do it maybe i'll do a little follow-up video of
some of the other ways we can perturb the system
but this was for u equals zero and u equals zero
and u equals zero it's very interesting to try out
what happens if the you know partial derivative in
y equals zero what if i have insulating boundary
conditions that changes uh these to g y you
know sub y of zero and h equals zero and that
would change this to being so that only the cosine
solutions can have their first derivative be zero
on these and so i'll get cosine solutions here
same fundamental eigenvalues same cinches here
but my uh gys would now be cosine functions if i
had insulating top and bottom if i put styrofoam
on the top and bottom of this so really cool
things once you know how this works you can
pretty much solve all of these problems
you could solve this on a circle on a disk
you could solve this on you know a ring you
could solve this on lots of different geometries
if you know this kind of basic procedure of you
know split plug it in solve your differential
equations solve the easy one first find your
eigenvalues plug it into the blue equation
last thing i'm going to do now so this is kind
of where the video ends except we don't have
these a n's so the last thing i'm going to do is
actually derive these ans and we're going to use
our boundary condition which is and i hope
i have room this is kind of a mess is that
you at my right boundary condition
you at x equals l of y equals this
f of y boundary condition i'm going to drop the
subscript 3 because i can't bear to write down
subscript 3 every time i have a y here and that
equals this summation up here so it equals my
sum uh from n i know everyone hates it when it
squeaks i'm sorry uh n equals zero to one um a n
goodness gracious uh a n
cinch
of and now all i'm going to do is anytime i
see an x i'm going to replace it with an l
it's that simple so i have n pi over h times
l this is a number that's actually easier
plugging in x equals l made this easier this
is just a number times sine of n pi over h y
okay good that this is just all i've done is
i've just re-capitulated my solution and i've
plugged in x equals l and i've said all of
this stuff and my solution has to equal my
right boundary condition at x equals l
it's that simple and now this is where
the fourier analysis comes in and it drives me
crazy that you know when i was going to school
fourier analysis was its own semester class and
everyone thought it would be really cool to learn
fourier analysis because it sounded you know neat
fourier analysis and isolation is boring fourier
analysis is a tool to solve partial differential
equations and physics equations and i think it's
a crime to you know separate it and quarantine
it off from uh from differential equations but
the way we're going to figure out these
a n's is what we're now going to do
is we are going to uh i'm just going to write this
out so i'm going to write out the essentially the
inner product of this function y so the inner
product and and if you don't remember what an
inner product is in a hilbert space a function
space i'll put a link to the video in my fourier
analysis series where i talk all about this it's
actually really easy it's the integral from 0 to h
of f of y times my sine n goodness gracious n or m
i'm going to use another variable m h n pi over h
y d y this is literally just breaking f of y into
fourier coefficients okay this is this is like the
projection of f onto the mth fourier coefficient
so this is the mph fourier coefficient of this of
this data f fy i think if this is data because
this is just a function that someone gives me
someone specifies and i get to use it and so i'm
going to compute its fourier transform and get
its fourier transform coefficients but now i'm
going to plug in all of this nonsense into that
f of y and i'm going to get something nasty but
things are going to cancel out okay so this equals
integral trying to make this not squeak
0 to h of my god awful sum of a and cinch
which is just a number sinch n pi l over h just
a number times this sign sine n pi over h y times
this sine sine m pi over h y d y now uh literally
i just took this is the fourier transform of f y
this is one of the terms of the fourier transform
of f y and i plugged in this expression of f
y my solution and what you'll notice now you
know these are just numbers these are numbers
and this inner product can only this this this
integral from 0 to h this is something you'll
learn in fourier analysis i call this an inner
product between these two functions these are
orthogonal functions if n is not equal to
m for any non-integer n and m for for any
integer n and m that don't equal each other this
integral is zero so this is only non-zero when
n equals m which means we can drop this uh we can
drop this summation here and this n has to equal m
okay and this n has to equal m and all of these
n's have to equal m's and i can probably just
make my ends m's without erasing them and so
essentially what we get is that this equals
a m
this integral from 0 to h will have a
length scale h again this is just details
over two this is just from this integral
i'm just showing you what the integral is
uh so so the integral forget all this junk this
is a constant this pops out the integral of these
two things when n equals m is just one half
times h it's h over two so i get h over 2 am
sinch m pi l over h good and so this
is what this integral equals okay
which means i can solve for am so now am and
i'll just call it a m equals this thing here
equals 2 over h sinch m pi l over h
moved all this over here times the integral from
0 to h of f of y sine m pi over h y d y this here
and let's just confirm this here is this
coefficient so this is a number number number
uh this is a function of specified numbers
and this is data this is my boundary condition
f of y so i can determine these a coefficients
purely from taking the fourier transform
so it's essentially just some constant
times the fourier transform coefficients
of my data on my right boundary condition so
that that's how you get these a n which i think
is kind of cool i know this made the video about
10 minutes extra long and some of you have fallen
asleep so you're welcome if it's late at night but
i think it's really really important to show that
you actually get these directly from you know this
this fourier transform this thing literally is uh
you know the nth fourier coefficient of f of y of
my data on my boundary condition so that's really
cool okay this is one of my absolute favorite
lectures because it tells you how to actually
solve pdes we haven't been playing around we
haven't just been writing down conservation
laws we actually wrote down the honest-to-goodness
solution you could plot this in python you could
plot this in matlab and you would actually
get the solution of laplace's equation for
for that you know this set of boundary
conditions all right thank you